- I'm on my way to Orlando and LA
and I want your suggestions
on what I should do there.
(Latin music)
(motor revs)
What's up believe nation?
Hope you're having an amazing weekend.
So I wanted your advice,
I want to hear from you.
I'm on my way to Orlando
and then LA in March.
One, Orlando is for my annual Disney trip.
It's a tradition that we
started a number of years ago
and we go every year, and
I'll be documenting it.
And we have one day off,
we've got a shopping day,
we've got Blue Jays baseball
spring training day,
we've got three days at Disney,
we've got one day at Universal Studios
which we're going to for the first time.
And I want to know what do you guys think?
Am I missing something?
What is the must do in Orlando
that I need to go check out?
If you're from Orlando I want
to get some comments down there as well.
And then I'm coming back for
like three day with Toronto
and I'm heading off to LA doing
something with Tony Robbins,
and then Lewis Howes,
and Brian Grazer in LA.
And I have half a day after, or before,
I have to figure out the exact day.
If any of you guys are in
LA and want to meet up,
let me know, leave it in the comments.
Maybe we can figure something out
and I can give you exact dates.
Let me see actually, when are we,
when does my, what is my LA day?
So in LA I have time on the 27th of March
either first thing in the
morning or in the late afternoon.
I think my last meeting starts at three,
so until, you know, starting
at five or whatever,
I'll be in Beverly Hills and
West Hollywood around there.
So if you're anywhere close
and you want to meet up let me know.
Or if you have suggestions of
what I need to go and do in LA,
that I haven't done before,
and you recommend I must check out,
let me know, leave it
down in the comments,
and hopefully I will
get a chance to do it.
Quick one this weekend for you guys.
Hopefully you are having an amazing one,
and I look forward to seeing your ideas,
listening to your feedback,
and maybe meeting up
with some of you soon.
Thank you guys for
watching, I believe in you.
Hope you continue to believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.